you have a reputation is not being  afraid to throw around a swear  occasionally as I did yeah as you just  did I do you feel you held your own with  Sam in that department trailer a lot the  morning so we talked about various and  sundry I just want to mention that none  of this will be seen on you could please  just spread the word about what happened  here fighting fighting with the Census  tonight I do think Sam though that  various and sundry mother is a great  memoir time thank you so tell all I  remember waiting to happen  you know I love the look that you have  in glass I think we have a picture here  they've got this incredible  what is that what is that hair modeled  after it looks familiar to me but I  don't know what it's from a photo of  Frederick Douglass Oh Frederick Douglass  okay makes sense Bush was a prince bang  yeah and had a lower back disorder yeah  yeah we got it all together now yeah  yeah hold me need to bust apart up in mo  you